yeah we have an announcement oh my god
what
we're having a baby big Kimye
announcement I love that and Chloe
gushes over her relationship with
Tristan Thompson it's been a few months
we interesting our grades I'm having so
much fun as the season 16 premiere of
Keeping Up with the Kardashians kicks
off with a bang it's not crazy Sunday's
episode gave fans a Chloe and Tristan
update we saw the couple doing just fine
ahead of the Jordan woods cheating
scandal
[Applause]
Tania even showed up in the confessional
interviews for the first time for a not
so conventional reason this is my first
time doing this I'm not actually
attempting to do good part of the reason
why I even thought about or considered
doing this this recording like the one
who caught what he call it's interview
this interview is because of the movie
The Incredibles then it starts off with
the interviews
the superheroes are given interviews the
wife got a big butt and I just see our
life becoming more and more and more
like The Incredibles until we could
finally fly the incredible family
announced they were going to be getting
a little bit bigger with the
announcement of baby number four so that
cranky give even shared the unexpected
family member that may have been the
first to spill the beans I'm not gonna
tell any of my friends I'm gonna tell
your friends cuz your friends are the
ones that came your Wyatt so I'm gonna
move to tell anyone I'm gonna call your
force Gina what you think our informant
is hmm Nora I'm really freaking out
you
[Applause]